voilà un moment que nous n'avions pas
entendu parler d'alain delon je suis une
star est il si le public tout acquis mon
fils partent depuis son avc en 2019
l'acteur français s'est fait plus
discret ce dimanche il s'est pourtant
confié sur sa vie au journal du dimanche
je me sens plutôt bien même si je suis
fatiguée que je marche avec une canne
mais on ne va pas faire de cinéma on
sait où on va et comment ça se finit sa
vie mais aussi sa fin de vie car à 86
ans alain delon confie est proche de la
sortie tous mes amis sont partis jean
paul belmondo l'année dernière romy
mireille darc nathalie delon toutes les
femmes de ma vie sont partis aussi si la
mort ne l'effraie pas il souhaite partir
sereinement quand il le désirera je veux
surtout avoir la paix mais j'ai peur de
souffrir je ne veux pas finir dans un
lit à l'hôpital alors alain delon se
confie sur sa mort et se dit favorable à
l'euthanasie êtes-vous d'accord
et c'est vrai qu'il a souvent dit que
l'on serait que tous ses potes à sont
tous partis sont seuls il a pas envie de
finir gras bataille que ça se comprend
oui moi je crois c'est le grand problème
de l'euthanasie d'ailleurs line renaud
l'évoquent aussi elle veut partir quand
elle leur a décidé moi je trouve que
vous respectez le choix c'est interdit
en france pour l'instant c'est le
dernier choix d'une vie moi je crois
qu'il faut le respecter absolument je
comprends alain delon on peut que le
comprendre et notamment quand on a été
comme ça une icône une légende et toute
cette beauté et je pense que forcément
le fait aussi de devoir la vieillesse de
voir ses amis qui meurt et tous
forcément on a envie de pouvoir décider
quand et comment donc madame parent et
non pas scandaleux au contraire ça me
paraît être une évidence c'est pas parce
que c'est une icône ou parce qu'il est
beau en fait c'est que chaque perte
chaque être humain est au même niveau et
chacun a le droit à sa dignité mais n'y
a pas de souci puisque d'autant plus
séparant a été nicolas d'autant plus
fort je suis désolé il ya des gens qui
sont est très très grand l'intellectuel
n'est pas moralement et qui
nous
a le droit de partir dignement et
effectivement voilà et ça je pense qu'il
faut le respecter c'est souffrir
souffrir dans un links c'est magali est
en train de dire c'est que alain delon
qui est qui en est donc le porte parole
parce que l'euthanasie c'est quand même
très compliqué c'est vrai que alain
delon n'a pas envie et je pense qu'il
peut faire passer un message de se
retrouver tout seul comme ça dans un lit
d'hôpital
souviendra-t-il c'est le cas et le
canada tout le monde mais c'est quand
même effectivement quelqu'un qui risque
d'avoir des paparazzi qui vient dans sa
chambre d'hôpital c'est quelqu'un qui
avait des trucs mais c'est un excellent
porte parole pour ça maintenant il faut
qu'ils aient un cadre attention parce
qu'il peut aussi avoir des dérapages ça
c'est sûr alors c'est autoriser ensuite
ça oui c'est possible dans quelques
notes américain également lui l'économie
toute façon non il n'a pas qu'il pas il
n'a pas de passeport suisse je crois que
si aaa est fortement pour demande
pourquoi
depuis toujours il est en quarts suisse
mais là mais le problème d'athènes de
l'on sait que la tuerie était obsédé par
la mort vraiment et voyez il a fait un
truc qui te mois veille personnellement
choqué mais que lui revendique comme
quoi c'est ce souvenir là qu'ils
voulaient garder il a pris la photo de
romy schneider morte dans son lit vous
savez oui c'est vrai et il a dans son
portefeuille
c'est lui même qui a pris la photo c'est
quoi le problème on brûle diffuse pas
son problème
non mais c'est cette conception c'est
cette obsession de la mort et il achète
trop tôt de romy schneider dans son
portefeuille il le dit lui même un jeu
je révèle pas un secret il le dit lui
même assez facilement moi ça me choque
personnellement et il a pris romy
schneider morte dans son lit et il le
garde sur lui dans son portefeuille
incroyable des films via des avancées
sur tellement de sujets je comprends pas
que l'euthanasie on n'avance pas plus
vite ou différemment parce que toutes
les personnes qui ont veillé quelqu'un
qui était au chevet qui allait mourir
ben on sait à quel point c'est difficile
et puis on a envie que ça s'arrête et
que ce soit le plus doux possible et
quand on meurt naturellement et bien
c'est pas facile et
moi j'ai perdu mon papa qui est qui
tardait tarder sur son lit d'hôpital
avec ma mère et qui est à son chevet à
son chevet je pense que ça va plus loin
parce que je pense que les gens ont du
mal justement à dire il faudrait que tu
partes même et les jambes je pense que
ma maman a peut-être voulu qu'ils
partent oui plus vite ils partie
malheureusement mais je pense que le
problème vient aussi là pour les
familles tu vois de se dire il faut
qu'ils savent haye mais j'ai pas il
fallait tout de suite je pense à ces
seules tu veux la voir souffrir moi
c'était plus qu'avec mon grand père est
au bout d'un moment ça dure est
tellement et je suis allé chez une
infirmière et je lui ai dit s'il vous
plaît vraiment entre nous parce qu'elle
me connaissait et ou machin il n'y a pas
moyen de l'aide parce que là il a du mal
à rester il n'y a pas moyen elle m'a dit
non on peut juste faire une sédation
j'ai dit ça veut dire quoi va faire
donner des médicaments pour que les gens
s'en rendent pas compte et petit à petit
je dis mais c'est pas possible vous
pouvez pas laisser ça elle a dit c'est
la loi on peut rien faire j'ai essayé je
lui ai fait des clins d'oeil j'ai dit
s'il vous plaît faites moi quelque chose
de la dinan pour rien et aujourd'hui
c'est ça en france pour des millions de
personnes je sais pas c'est pas un sujet
pour l'instant qui est sur la table du
20e mois non non non non même line
renaud l'a évoqué enfin il faut rappeler
que il est encore le temps alain delon
j'espère il avait 86 ans et ça va à peu
près donc j'espère que ce sera avec nous
longtemps quand le plus tard possible